Oh back in studio second studio
it's Wednesday my psoriasis is if I
flare it up thank you Huntsville thank
you for all the food around there I
think I think it's the food that flared
up you look like you have you look like
it I look like you look like a cheetah
but with red white and red who brought
that who shaved Brussels Valentine's Day
cheetah
yeah who shaved the cheetah and gave it
a bunch of welts it looks like it looks
like like a like someone had like a fire
poker and just poked the [ __ ] up your
legs
somebody throw your legs somebody hit
you with a with a ripe tomato who
ceiling shoots camera man hitches yeah
it's not contagious
no I don't know I started getting it
when I was I went to a jail to do this
right this time right in that I saw I
went to the psych ward and I saw how
they treated people and I it was so
stressful I almost started crying there
in front of the guards you know me yeah
I'm not very comfortable with oh [ __ ]
must've been horrible well think about
this so you know me I'm dead behind the
eyes was that [ __ ] all right you start
crying and I'm like I'm funny make fun
of you when I was returning I'm a grown
man I'm probably 30 probably I think I
was 34 probably 33 young not young and
they take day time a little bit of a
celebrity for them you know that I'd
done some stuff and they took me up to
all these places you don't get to go as
a civilian and I get taken to the jail I
see a guy who gets stabbed the first day
12 times big giant what's the worst
that's gonna happen
a giant black dude all muscle look like
Mike Tyson and still want the fight and
it's good instead yeah his girl was
there and and and she was with him and
he was all bandaged up he's gotta let
him know I let that [ __ ] know he
liked the screaming and she goes hey
look at me I'm here for you no matter
whatever I'm here she loved her man and
here's this I was just thinking about
this this young black couple it all
sucks
it all sucks and he's in jail and it all
sucks and I don't know how to help him
then I saw the dude that stabbed him and
please he bigger uh he was he was metric
clearly
they he was clearly in a strong safety
in that in the NFL about six-two he was
wearing a towel on his head and a small
towel just around his nether real rented
like a [ __ ] take you a beautiful
a beautiful black a beautiful black to
his skin yeah and and because it was
very hot and I had any looked at me and
I looked at him with respect he's a
beautiful human beautiful human and I
looked at him and I didn't want to be
the guy who was looking at him like an
animal in a cage but that is what I was
doing cuz he was in a cage and behind
glass as well and he just he looked at
me and all he could ever age yes it was
like it was like oh you just get done
stuff yes yes it was a walking [ __ ] you
to the world yeah but there was
something about a man and I've never
forgotten the look in his eye and I was
walked by and I looked and then I
realized because that's the guy who
stabbed them and I looked away because I
didn't want to be I don't want to be
looking at him yeah you don't want him
to feel like even more yeah and he also
had a lot of dignity you can see but I
thought to myself there was something
about that look I like sometimes you see
one look in one expression one person
and you think there's all the injustice
in the world wrapped up and there that
kid was that with a kid someday yeah it
used to be a kid and then whatever
happened in the world where he became
that behind a cage what a waste of a
[ __ ] human being was what a waste of
a human moment it sucks and by the way
when you're in miami-dade county jail a
jail that Amnesty International tried to
close down because it was violating
their human rights they had you want to
talk about skin diseases they had
[ __ ] mersa everything's like rampant
they had that flesh-eating bacteria all
over the place crazy
so some Ursula though they had
everything that Mercer they had
flesh-eating that dad some of this other
Nick rightist they had all kinds of
crazy skin things there so why did I
have you done looking for Oz I was there
to believe it ought to write about calm
I'll tell you because it's a great story
but so I'm it's and so by the way
they're always hungry cuz you don't get
a lot of food the food three meals and
yeah the lunch is unjust sandwich yes
one slice of ham and it's a waiting it's
out you wait in that jail until you are
you you're trying to go to prison be
years it could be years it can be years
and it what and it is years so I see
that dude and I'm like damn and that's
already stressful
I'm like [ __ ] this is huh okay moving on
moving on move on then they take me I
meet I meet a guy named Sam cameras last
name he is a guy who had a TV show from
jail he worked in the jail and he had
like a reality show yeah it's like a
reality show it was like it was like
something that would go on
closed-circuit TV and everybody would
watch it and he'd have eaten interview
prisoners and he's like the news of the
day it's amazing amazing guy I spent all
my sent away from Ward three Carl
stabbed the guy in the neck we're trying
to get it cleaned up literally that's
what he'd say and Friday is crazy
wardrobe day so go ahead and die you're
flam they had a warden in miami-dade
County a long time ago a black guy who
had those guys going to school he had
them doing activities he had them
watching educational movies I mean he
was making such a difference then a
reporter this investigative reporter was
like we're coddling these prisoners and
he lost his job
Wow because he was trying to make a
difference again another guy I remember
think about yeah got to know certain
prisoners there was with them one guy
gave him up my my address and he was
returning to be very gay and was was
very thuggish black guy strong very gay
even gave him a phone number why would
you because he was so nice to me he was
so nice to me and he called me and wrote
me letters for six years and I'm not
talking at one point he got me he goes
man I want to see you man I want to look
at you I just sent me a picture any
picture I don't give you give me send me
a picture I'm like I'm not playing dumb
he goes I want to see you a little man I
want to see you dance or look like a
goddamn good you got good-looking 35
you're a good-looking 36 he wanted a
dick pic so badly this is before you can
do it on your phone just send him a god
he asked me to describe what what I was
I was hitting and what I was wearing and
I was like all right man and I kept
going man you know I'm just with my girl
so I can't really do that but anyway my
girl and I I mean I gotta eat the exam
burger you like
a real appetite he didn't give a [ __ ]
then he like Gary was in prison and then
he like told me uh he's got an AB and he
wants to our been called all in and it
would be sangmi he sang me a song
disobey me a song I'm not exaggerating
and it was this and I'm not kidding us
and it was just like a terrible I was
like boys sing better and I'm not a
singer you haven't collect call from
Miami girl it's your white boy girl
what's going on yeah well you know what
you know I had a gay relationship I had
a care relation him with a guy who had
killed several people
what his crimes were they were not good
kill his first guys 15 oh don't don't
[ __ ] my life up wow man you could dump
[ __ ] my life up then then I don't [ __ ]
my life up again yeah what I'm doing
here yep he just wanted to get a diamond
stud in his nose but they're not letting
them it was a problem I was like okay I
could send ya how about I smuggle a
diamond stud in my ass you just trying
to please people so your friend like we
do them and I fly to Florida man I get
this guy won't quit harass me
so I bought a ticket I'm dating up on a
diamond as for moms in and out it was
flying in and out man and I'll take care
of you God I kept that relationship
going on for about six years its court
captain kept another relationship going
on for another guy for another ten years
so it's and oh and ask me if I sent him
money all the time all the time you buy
stick I'm an [ __ ] I don't know I
can't [ __ ] awesome yeah the world's
like that when we write I don't know how
to make it to sex when we're walking
down Abba and that homeless going to hug
me are you what the [ __ ] you doing man I
go like this and here's how you like oh
what's up man like Brian what are you
doing this right
yeah that's right because he recognized
yeah who's this crazy so then I go they
take me to where they house their
mentally disturbed people one guy by the
way had apparently I believe committed
child rape or done something to children
even the guards were like he did some
[ __ ] with children they they didn't want
to tell me everyone hates him like he
was yeah but yeah you hate him until you
see that he's wearing a nylon poncho in
a sleeping on a steel slab in a an
aquarium it's an aquarium if he murdered
kids under glass they deserve and he was
he was clutching the air and talking to
himself he was crazy he was [ __ ]
crazy and then what you would see is
it'll be better put him down well I know
it sounds awful it's what you say put
him down but so we put him to claims and
lock them in there when they're when
they're not right in the head
so so a lot and we don't have a lot of
because we don't have the room in
hospitals and also mental diagnosis is
very very difficult this is why wouldn't
talk about somebody who shot everybody
up and at school well where was the
psychiatrist actually designating
somebody a danger to society is very
very so tough and so a lot of people say
only how's our crazies we house our
mentally disturbed in jails a lot of
times that's a big secret that people
fight for yeah I'm not trying to flee
continue the story please bring up
Jonathan Martin that the accent of the
football player who got arrested because
he was thinking about shooting up his
old high school who played in the NFL I
saw this save that for image so he's so
I go there and well they keep you in
essentially what's a glass cage and they
have somebody watching you so a guard
has to sit in front of your aquarium in
a in a plastic chair a guard and he sits
and looks at you and the reason he had
to say yeah at the mentally disturbed
person and the reason he has to do that
is because he has to watch it's called
suicide watch he's got to watch you so
that you don't try and oh by the way you
will not have any shoelaces you'll not
have use all that nothing so what you do
is you have a nylon poncho you wear a
poncho that's made of nylon and you
sleep on it and it was so traumatic to
me that I I almost
to cry right there like I had never very
rarely if I had a meltdown respect bro I
I had a meltdown and I and he the guards
saw that I was about to lose that job
and he goes get him out he goes hey you
got to get him out of here you can't
bring him in here without telling him
what to expect he doesn't know what to
do with this too much you don't know
what to do it be the older kind of brain
doesn't probably God for that yeah well
I broke psoriasis my legs broke out
those are first biases outbreak and
because I couldn't sleep I'll sue the
over like did he give you good words of
I never showed him my legs cuz I didn't
want him to be did not be attracted and
I don't get surprised I'm I'm my ass
hold the pictures I hope how crazy is it
like I've been to jail when I add a
project for when I was at university
Colorado I was doing a lot of I think it
was crime and something I forget what
the classes were just occipital justice
and one of the things my buddies dad was
high up but judged some but he got
access to a jail in Denver like a rough
jail and so we went on a field trip in
college on how that works there's only
three of us I remember walking through
and even then you really have
perspective in college right you're
still kind of in this security bubble
where you're on campus you're in dorms
eat here train here go to school here
sleep here like it's still kind of
either that bubble not the real this
college isn't the real world and then
when you go to jail I'm gonna walk you
mind seeing guys my age or older guys I
remember like holy [ __ ] man this is what
it's like for them yeah and that you
know they're doing a 20 or bit yeah and
you're walking through you're just like
how like you don't it gives you you
didn't even that doesn't give you
perspective but even I was just like
think of his life think of my life what
in the hell man then again you could be
stevie blue eyes who went to federal
penitentiary and had still keeps in
touch with his friends there and he like
this is it so he goes he goes he goes if
there are women there I wouldn't have
left because I hung out my buddies all
day we worked out and we laughed all
[ __ ] hardly I've ever laughed was
with my he had a Haitian roommate and
and his other roommate who was a 7-foot
400-pound black guy and he shows we call
that yes
smartest [ __ ] funniest [ __ ] and Stevie
what loved it he's always a great great
time man you know what he said about
certain like sometimes they can tell if
you're you've been a dick on the outside
is if nobody sends you money oh for sure
and they're like why why is why do you
have not one person how that's a bad
side yeah they're like watch out for
that can we talk about like we have some
acquaintances that have they don't have
they don't have any old friends
no one from high school don't from
college town perhaps no one from you
know like oh you were comic in Boston
yeah who you don't bust now talk to any
of them man right all in San Francisco
I'm a comment or whatever comment I'm
saying they're comics but oh do you know
this guy's Terrace ago I used to man
don't don't talk to many more such a
weird thing god it's so weird to me I
got one person like that in my life too
two people two people in my life if my
51 years that I I had that and even
really really it's one really it's one
and it's okay sometimes you have a
falling out somebody's got [ __ ] but
don't know but all of them all the time
something's going on you might be the
one calm you might have in fact yeah I
won't comment enough yeah that's what's
it well yeah and also people who are
yours here that's like that my favorite
is like um and you know we just don't
see eye to eye man you know I mean at
the end of the day I realize this guy's
trying to [ __ ] me if you think the
world's trying to [ __ ] you it's there's
something wrong if you if you blame the
world for [ __ ] you if you if you
everybody gets a raw deal that is the
most self-defeating [ __ ] philosophy
in the world I don't care what happened
what happened I don't care watch this
tell me my all that matters is are you
are you gonna get in the job done no no
cuz nobody cares
does anybody really care what do you do
I promise especially at some older
buddies they're getting into certain
things I could definitely help with and
then when I sit down and go over the
play and stuff like that and thought and
I just don't have time because they
haven't really thought it out they
haven't thought of that are they their
own are the architects of their own kind
of know what it's like and I'm not never
want to say choose a lane but they're
all over and then when I seem going to a
certain line of work and they know I've
been doing it for a while to go Oh
making you help me
and like I could there's there's so much
to go over man well no I like about you
and I like about you and I've always
noticed is if there's a task to be done
it does not matter you don't care like
it doesn't matter like oh your neck is
broken
um era when you had you couldn't move
your neck and your girl was like why
don't you say anything about it and you
go cuz it doesn't do anything it doesn't
matter you get my favorite story is when
you hurt your knee and you didn't you
got an x-ray and Lauren Lando this is
the most genius thing anybody could ever
do it's an amazing story
Lauren lamb that goes does it matter
what I tell you it doesn't matter if you
have a torn ACL or does it not because
you're still gonna fight right so does
it matter yep cuz we got Siri for life
and how about Lauren he yesterday was
I'm so glad to empower this guy he was
killer before Lauren Landau at Landale
performance so he's always wanted the
job for the Denver Broncos and I've said
it on here before he got the gig he's
had strength go to the Denver Broncos
your state was his first day well how
cool is that
Wow oh [ __ ] that's a that's the pinnacle
oh yeah nothing bigger than that it's
amazing and he's been passed over so
many times for just these knuckleheads I
never understood it I worked with him
for one day and that is why I'm so
strong I make sense yeah curious right
that's why I can know he gave me
psoriasis a lot of weight see that's
going back to prison i watch that show
60 days in I think after I have you know
at six days in so it's people from the
regular civilians in the outside world
who have some connection to prison or
jail so maybe their dad growing up
served their brothers in prison for life
something and they want to know what
they're going through
so they voluntariness a real program
that in in all over the country but this
is a real program in Atlanta where these
six people voluntarily go to prison for
60 days and their implants to let the
warden know where the jail no the holes
the the what the issues they see and
it's always the staff the staff is
terrible at these jails like one guy was
in trouble and he goes I hit my panic
button and the in the warning did they
check in every day by the way what
warden and he was I hit the panic button
because I felt threatened and he goes
and what happened was no one came the
entire night what happens if I was
literally in trouble like we don't know
we gotta fix the buttons like yeah no
[ __ ] man
and then there they're smuggling all
these drugs but there's this attractive
lesbian girl on this new season
I think season just wrapped was there
subtractive lesbian girl and she goes in
there and she's what they call stud in
the lesbian world so she you know she
she she's very pretty I don't if you can
bring her up but she she's very pretty
and show she's in the female dishes yeah
there she is she's in the female cook on
that both third one down four on the
left the bottom layout on the left yeah
she is black girl she's beautiful human
being all tied up shredded - yeah and so
she goes into the into the jail and
she's like you know I'm my my family or
something was in here I don't know what
it's like she's like this would be easy
work so she gets in and she's a beast
like right away everyone respects her
she's doing her thing she goes in she
goes full you never go full prisoner oh
she had a girlfriend who she told about
the whole show she whispered to her the
whole show what she's doing in there and
then she also was starting to fight
other prisoners and the war took its I
like what are you doing you're supposed
to be helping us she's like I just I
feel like I feel like one of them what
do you want to do so when she told her
girlfriend who she's supposed to move in
with now who has a drug issue a serious
drug issue who she told her girlfriend
they yanked her from the show they had
to cancel it the whole show harm because
now their safety because once they know
you're snitch oh they're gonna oh then
it shows like survivor take it show guy
gang members like Bloods initiating or
if someone has a problem with one guy
they lock the door just shows him
getting their ass it's a fascinating
show did you have lost nothing besides
my entertainment
nothing always like they sit down and
they dude like a whole conclusion like
so what did you learn he's like it's
[ __ ] up the way you guys treat them
and there's drugs in there he's like
very cool thank you yeah that's it yes
no fun oh well she was thriving she
looks like a handsome young man I'll be
honest with you and
I mean in a bad way but no geez like a
beautiful person she's a good-looking
good-looking him and good-looking human
is she almost beat up this one girl she
looks like an athlete and tough
that's her girl right there uh no her
girl I wonder if the shoulder I wonder
if they're still together so Mike
Michael Tate my old girlfriend went to
jail for five months and she got a
girlfriend and she was adorable and she
she had a pretty good time she had a
pretty good time in jail so like you got
all day you're going to jail what
happens you guys I had fun
guys like Stevie thrive in that in why
do I get along with everyone I'm saying
I if I if I can't spread my wings and
see the ocean and sip coffee and talk
I'm your [ __ ] we'd be sitting there
talking to people and you know suck each
other off I mean you know whatever
happens happens you know what I mean bro
it's prison bro it's prison I've heard
guys say that like bright ain't gay hell
not AJ soon when I got back with my
woman man but in here I'll turn that ass
no Harry Connick jr. was doing a roll
and so he went to Angola the farm in
empty that's in that's in Louisiana
that's a that is a very hard hard prison
he grew a really long beer any soft
prisons well this is one of the most
notorious for sure but once back is
basically I want an Arizona what would
they do
he's basically slavery oh that's the
movie life okay there it is
and so Harry Harry went there and he was
on a tractor and he was kind of working
and stuff and he was undercover he's
doing this for a movie and a dude came
up and goes now what you don't
understand sits father was District
Attorney
put a lot of people away put a lot in
that jail so the guy comes up and goes
you do dad put me away bro it's all good
I know you are and Harry thought it was
being on fire there he goes oh [ __ ] he
goes hey Ben a lot of people know who
you are I mean but they never [ __ ] with
out you know but then they think they're
being undercover even on six days in
right away so I was like snatch their an
implant well when you're they know right
away and also apparently if you're not a
snitch and you're not really cute
usually be alright you're good yeah I'm
you don't know is in there you don't be
a child
they tell things to their like you know
don't make a scene don't talk a whole
lot right when you get in like don't be
annoying just meet just chill and
be fine be chill yeah I'd be like this
sucks you know there's a cool place in
California I think in LA we can rent a
room in prison or jail for $200 a night
so much experience it also you can do
this to my buddy we got a DUI I was
gonna go to jail but then he was able to
pay to have like a room where he had to
stay in this room instead of going to
jail nicer
I guess rent the room in jail
renting no I don't wanna do that upgrade
to jail cell for a price room for rent
in jail Road I'd upgrade the [ __ ] out of
my dude if we could get if we go to
prison for one night I don't do more
than one night cuz we're gonna be up all
night it's not when he dicks in my mouth
bro me up all night it'd be fun if
they're trying to [ __ ] you they better
pack a lunch you gotta have to like ass
the homies like ace that dude yeah you
may have for the UFC used to watch me we
should [ __ ] him I'm not doing [ __ ] about
it when there's a shank at my neck first
of all well you know I'm gonna say
you're gay so of course you know I'm not
what I mean well yeah yeah well not when
they use my excuse Schenk that's better
get away or I'm gonna put you in a
triangle tell me if this gonna work for
you they get the shake out I go straight
up Andy Dufresne I go you can put that
shank into my skull now but you put your
dig anything put my mouth I clench down
and bite hard
mm-hmm that's Andy Dufresne and it works
sometimes with the [ __ ] sometimes now
and then it worked
all right now yeah now and then wish I
could say that was a movie man our best
movie ever
Oh watch doing so many times oh here it
is Airbnb listen offers thrill-seekers
the chance to spend one night in Erie
Florida form no I don't need for our
present dude I need the real [ __ ] chin I
need the real [ __ ] I mean it's hilarious
about prison not to have more than weird
time like this how about making afraid
reach out to us we're talking about
forever and I was thinking about that
I'm not getting nettles in my food be
[ __ ] with your psoriasis yeah I can't
I can't be in the Sun I can't be gone
for 21 days and I mean do you think we'd
last no you don't think you and I would
last you know you can meet with like a
nature expert beforehand the teachers
like fire and how come each other's
mouths like so
I you know you know what I I don't want
to be in a desert and I don't know if I
would be like Nicaragua I prefer a
desert o-over jungle
hold on literally bugs in the jungle
let's just cover the desert real quick
no water hot hot during the day - well
me so hot do it right no water in waters
you mean what is the most important part
of the holidays so water there's also no
plans meditation so there's no bed or
sleeping on sad night freezing freezing
the jungle were shaded bunch of leaves
and stuff we make cool costumes together
I play Jumanji into the jungle in the
jungle what they don't tell you about
jungle is it you get weird funguses and
you get lots of stings and you're a fox
sy Olsen oh did you get stings you get
all kinds of [ __ ] poisonous snakes
everywhere in our ass holes are just
wide open like bug dogs I don't walk
around my [ __ ] wide open I don't know
we're gonna be tracking I don't want to
be barefoot naked she's not the gay
getaway dude I know it's not but our
dicks and asses in this house 9 this is
not the gay getaway that's the first
thing you do that you're that guy on
this show that oh god I got a cover-up
that's the first thing I'm coming with a
crotch weave I'm figuring out a way a we
grow I'm figuring out a way to cover my
three-piece set with well I mean sturdy
ly I'm gonna celebrate it I'm gonna I'm
gonna make some some fine shoes I'm
gonna have my style go diva in the
jungle some fine shoes that look just
like this and then I'm just a soul open
okay here's what I'm doing and I'm gonna
set some traps you don't know how to set
traps I do I'm setting traps I'm
catching myself a couple furry furry
little forest creatures probably rabbit
- whatever let's meet up now when your
three-piece set is nestled in rabbit fur
super hard to have a bad day you
understand you walk it's not a bad idea
you understand so my 3-piece set is all
kinds of nests nestled but for now I'm
gonna make myself some monsters I'm [ __ ]
I'm gonna find a magnet for if I yep but
I'm gonna find a sleeping I'm gonna find
a sleeping fawn and I'm gonna jump on it
and I'm a little baby deer I'm gonna
kill it
I'm gonna kill it drink its blood drink
you just lied and
then I'm gonna I'm gonna skin him and
I'm gonna make some moccasins out of
them out that out that that deerskin so
my feet are covered use his eyeballs his
ear plugs his nose like Gobstopper not I
don't know I don't know what to do
anymore
though then we're just spitballing idea
no but I don't like your ideas you know
I'm not putting wet eyeball deer
eyeballs in my [ __ ] ears all right
clogged the sound of night I want to
think I need my ears to hear for prey
then I'm gonna catch me a forest fowl be
content to my game plan yeah hopefully
we're in an area were there sloth and we
just live off the sloth
I love of nice sloth it's actually one
of my favorite animals kept they're so
goddamn slow they climbed way up in the
tree you're gonna be the client Radley
I'm the climber or we better learn how
to just Ross throw a hard rock yeah or
spear right between the eyes you know
easy then he falls we're gonna eat some
monkey we need some sloth and we're not
a monkey but yeah we're gonna wear it
we're gonna wear his skin we're gonna
wear that [ __ ] we're gonna walk
around in sloth skin and then we'll have
to is pet now we don't want to be in
Costa Rica here's why at the eyelash
Viper that kind of hangs out on the side
of it I'll be the one hit first I'm
taller darts out darts out bites right
in the [ __ ] face not to mention the
goddamn crocodile is basically but
actually madhubuti Costa Rica the now
are those call girls all over Costa Rica
in the jungle or well now I don't know
why you would even talk about that but
I've heard I've heard that there are
call girls in that area all over the
jungle that's what I've heard
I will I've heard that there are
brothels where you can pay money to have
sex with women now if that's what you're
talking about which I don't I'm married
to you till I'm married but apparently
you can get three or four what you can
afford
literally and I'm not so all you have is
$40 of beef jerky
we'll take I'm married but but yeah I
guess there are places you can go and
you can say here's 300 bucks
I'd like all for a cheap hotel for the
night and then you can have sex with
them and there are more there's a bar
there where it is a frenzy
dick frenzy dick friends and crazy
shouldn't go in there Tina chin you
would get laid here easily 70 oh yeah we
have been real pretty mouths are
salivating for dick and you go and then
I went oh my god it was like zombies
yesterday it actually the point you know
you're like there's got to be a lot of
disease run running around this whole
thing guys and everything it's just like
whoa and the girls look good at first
but then you get up close and you're
like aw boy and there's packs like
they're they're just gangs of them
they're like there's four friends here
ah poppy for two for $20 with $20 that
can I turn it down yeah yeah that's a
deal I know they forced it it's like
when you're going to do anywhere like I
don't need more shoes with $20 I might
as well [ __ ] taking for a spin I
could try a live now thing if you went
to shoe store in like four pairs of
shoes for twenty dollars like okay all
right I don't need it I probably
shouldn't
I was worried I'll use protection I was
worried I'm gonna wake up without a
kidney or something you know I mean you
know I don't drink anything bro just
water I do it water do not give me I'm
telling you chin we should send you down
there with the chin cam bro that that
camera is gonna come back like a goddamn
shark whites nose just [ __ ] weather
shark why there's [ __ ] all sorts of
crazy marks on it
he's so excited about yeah what I say
you guys it's coming back with a shark
whites nose yeah
great whites just my fifth show in two
days it's the beach yeah I'll do that
you know I'm saying though Jim you gotta
I'm too scared I got them
see that's why I will send you down
there bro Chandler man you've been
bungee jumping
hell no I think that's silly I've been
with me that's silly right now hidden
bungee jump in a crowd full of [ __ ]
and by being bungee jump I mean coming
to this bar with your dick out and a fat
cash no let me ask you this you ever um
you ever kill a man no you know a bunch
of people don't know I kill the guy yep
Brian killed again I ate him with some
fava beans
hell no more the professional no uh hold
on
I know what Brian's ranking on there Jen
real quick and you'd be dead honest no
one's listening killer you ever paid for
the company of a warm-blooded woman what
do you mean by company ah you know there
we go
we talked about the karaoke player get a
girl ever give a girl five hundred bucks
hell no oh hold on tell them you weren't
here for this huh there's like a karaoke
underground in Koreatown la tell Brian
about this greatest place of all time
versus uh I don't know how people get
away with it but they bring in girls
from different countries sex trafficking
bred so there's no sex though right so
they bring in girls from different
countries there's like Russian girls
Koreans Japanese I can tell you who the
brings without a doubt guys without a
doubt yeah they're great people guys you
don't [ __ ] with I'm not [ __ ] with
there oh but they need money I have
money
that's all we're friends underground
karaoke but they bring these girls in an
underground but it's everywhere you can
drive by them but then you won't but
he'll never be able to get in chip in
there yeah because my boss the company I
work for before was a big Korean
television network and obviously they're
connected to you know people as well
here's my thing kid get us the [ __ ] in
hell
you don't mean Brian be a life of the
party these things I'm telling you I
couldn't do it you got to be like you
have to have connections but I mean it's
everywhere so you go so it's a basically
a brothel
coyote are you bro how did you want to
get it or not it's fancy karaoke you
ever saying oh my god no I want to sing
I want to sing have you ever saying I
want to sing for Russian girls and
Colombian girls I Dream Weaver in a dick
so if you even tried to get your dick
sucked I think people would run in and
beat the crap out crazy bro can you
pretend Dream Weaver can you bring up
the the lyrics I've been on this earth
for 34 years 35 Sunday you crazy if you
think those girls are only there to
watch you sing bro and share the drinks
at you put no go pow yeah the old 51
year old gay al and we run in a trailer
suppose the dream weed baby yes you beat
the Mafia would destroy they wouldn't
they those girls aren't there just to
have a good time chin they're not
they're not allowed to leave with anyone
they'd be getting shipped in and I don't
know what's that leaving the premises
weird right or singing Dream Weaver
while we're there ladies everybody in
Russia comment what you guys this is
this is this is for you Oh
Dream Weaver no don't start no no I just
yeah you using the course right all
right
that's why I hit though because I can't
really think I'll say money of course do
it can we can wait where's you hear it
do we get some sounds here at first we
have to most of this out okay but just
just let let Brennan here at first and
then we're gonna do it one of my
favorite songs and then we're gonna do a
render just close right that's right
that's actually good all right let me
hear it on oh what a great that's a
great song what a reference Dream Weaver
in a dicksuck welcome hmm that's it
Pontius it's so good hold on
without the date sex we get so dicks
like shirts long and sugared just wanna
begin along it choice right beginning
just uh and then we're gonna do it and
chin you're you're like okay you know
how good this guy's voices see my pants
are off and I'm like this onstage
singing chin look I'm like this hey
singer Brian see on the driver of the
Dreamweaver bro you know I'm saying
tomorrow I believe you can get me
through the night half hey ok near Lord
oh man I've got worse worse right here
Dreamweaver I believe we can reach the
morning LA hi
okay thank you thank you Oh too careful
of my pants Oh me through this starry
skies oh [ __ ]
to an astral plane great songs all time
Wow their music is that the official
music here at bottom right across the
highway yeah yeah please no one's gonna
be able to see this [ __ ] up job eight
million view size it to sing that song
can you sing that song I'm not never
heard the song oh sorry oh hey bro are
you from really for Russia this dude's a
plant yeah from North Korea [ __ ] you
know what do you know what dude that's
pens in town convenient dude and and Kim
Jong is getting him to infiltrate media
both those my we that powerful here
again Oh God
sing him it why is he blue like it's
Marines no man but God bless sure he
looks like an extra out of frighteners
Michael J Fox reference hooves nope [ __ ]
you too man
you guys can't hang i'm writers
frighteners all my fighters fans you
know what's up I know this part man
through
[Music]
so this sought we won't be able play any
this so this song I've always been such
a huge fan of song yeah and when
University of Colorado the way the
initiate freshman is during the dinner
time when the entire team all the staff
the coaches wives are their families
it's like 300 people and eating this
cafeteria the freshmen have to get up
with a mic and sing a song and it's not
awesome
no can see it's not a thing but is it
taking it seriously or is it challenge
but oh my god would you know it's coming
so you got to try and figure something
out the night before but you have not
they might get you that night they may
get you in two nights it's during the
training camp so you basically have two
weeks and you have no idea what night
you're gonna go up so the freshmen
eating like [ __ ] stress as [ __ ] and
then a guy come around the mic like yo
shop get up man your turn like ah [ __ ]
and the one that seniors during practice
like what are you gonna say I'm like I'm
a singing Weaver anyway what I'm gonna
try Dream Weaver they go I'm gonna do
wheel kick but I can't I've never I
never done a sport hello seeing Dream
Weaver and then went well we don't know
that [ __ ] song and it sounds terrible
let me hear it I went oh isn't from all
black guys I go oh Dream Weaver not stop
give us something else no I don't know
songs new stuff so at home and I sing
that year Smith Rain Purple Rain I heard
a guy try to sing that song with a live
band is really a great present Purple
Rain the guys who did best was the guy
super HAP because you can wrap it like
you don't need talent can trapeze
memorize it well no I'm saying if you're
if you're doing that type of thing
wrappings the way to go I'm not gonna
rap you know I'm not rapping yeah
I sang that Aerosmith song what's the
one from Armageddon
oh I sang it to coach Barnett and
everyone dude that's hilarious
what is it play it for me cheer I don't
want to miss a thing I don't wanna miss
a thing
like
this is by the way coach more debt coach
Barnett he goes chop come down come down
and I was just kept singing alright
we've had enough come on down before
chair that's enough that's enough all
right this is terrible let's sing it
right to him oh my god but the night
before I studied all the lyrics
everything I mean Stephen Tyler can sang
120 million views yeah that's how it
gets Steven Tyler now imagine seeing
this to your coach he's amazing imagine
seeing us to a grown man in front of
your friends type move though look at
him he's him but you can't sing this was
bad this is the one that Tyson Fury sing
right yeah this is different no this is
the a Tyson Fury saying this yeah good
good
by the way how good is this [ __ ]
how great of a movie is Armageddon Remo
that have choked you up when Bruce
Willis goes take care of my daughter
it's Ben Affleck and he pushes him and
then he flies back home and then Bruce
Willis blows the whole [ __ ] meter
right up he does it he's surfing he's
sacrificed Oaks out I get choked up
doing that okay that's right there's
only one way so you take care of my
daughter
there's only one way he's all cool take
care of my kids
Brennan love the kids and satisfy my
wife mmm see you later all right fine
we won't be able to play this either
yeah great I can move those masts don't
wanna miss a thing cuz I miss you babe
you remember her looking that young yeah
I do she's Wow Ben Affleck man people
here on the men's crew he's been killing
freezers months wider and by the way how
straight every grace of her great
director the town sounds amazing
I mean Batman you know it's not his
fault see castle in Rome well he's
outstanding right Ben Affleck spooge
Affleck for outstanding great director
always does his job as an actor good guy
does he ever
I'm telling you see the movie where he
plays a gangster
and they send me to Florida then he goes
to Tampa Florida to get things done big
kid apparently every bit it's not
smaller three big Irish kid Don Baby
Gone the town Argo oh it slipped by the
night god damn that movie is good I wish
on a plane it's been a lot of time me
Road Dogg the Road Dogg so I see all
these don't make me mad yeah double Road
Dogg by the way I'm doing Boston I'm
doing Boston right I'm at the at laughs
Boston what is it a roll whatever yeah
yeah oh yeah April 19 20 21 all right
yeah 19 20 2000 Rogen shooting is
special at the Wilbur but you know what
I'm selling well because I think I'm
getting the run off on people like a can
make it a Rogen I'm coming over to count
but he's shooting his special
back-to-back right yeah so he's gonna
actually I don't know if I can say this
out loud but Rogen I'm spiking jump on
my Thursday show I'll be cool [ __ ]
he's gonna do a good hour damn yeah yeah
you should have stuffs without the
Wilbert that's right yeah the Rikuo I'm
not even open for him on my own show
maybe I'll do like 45 and then have him
come on maybe he'll open for me I don't
[ __ ] know so look you guys don't know
either way cool though sick yeah um yeah
see live by the night man the writer was
dope well let's not get crazy on the
runner right you just been doing work
man hi well that's our time that's hard
- hey gentlemen I think we've covered
everything right now we've covered it oh
that's our time yet some kind of engine
yeah oh hey jacked [ __ ] was that shake
check I didn't sleep well so I had to uh
grab something real quick to eat and
they knock out for a little while you
guys okay
no hold on real quick you know just for
Petey up for guys suffering from PTSD
this is just something I just wanted to
say it's very real
no I'm going to do this has been sending
me all these like they're finding like
really really good results like for
Maori so so certain Maori you
in New Zealand who suffer from mental
health problems and abuse and PTSD guys
what they're finding is like in a lot of
these programs when they get in touch
with mythology like Homer's Iliad or or
the Maori people about their gods and
stuff it gives them a frame of reference
to deal with adversity and pain and stop
saying that tell them PTSD Allah sounds
like some a lot [ __ ] or not because
it'll American American CTS DSC in touch
with fake gods no no not not Maori gods
but like so right now they're reading
Homer and Homer which has been around
for I don't know three thousand years
might have something to offer it's about
a soldier it's about Odysseus is deal
how he deals with grief on the
battlefield and how he deals so maybe
it's hoping we cope with it but it's not
what assuring anything was helping them
is and this is from them not from me
this is from people suffering from TPC
Odyssey who've been through the program
is that it's helping them put into
context they're suffering so yeah so
Jordan Peterson has had a lot of real
real success with a lot of people he's a
clinical psychologist in helping young
men with PTSD on women with PTSD but a
lot of young men because he creates a
frame of reference any-any references a
lot of mythology and you references a
lot of examples in history of how human
beings are are capable of doing
inexplicably terrible things to other
people in the heat of battle and and
allowing them to realize that we all
have a sign of that yeah and so he's
helped him deal with it they're not
curing it no Kara whatever curing means
yeah he's helping these people a lot of
people are having trouble coping because
they can't put a shirt so they can't
really in the content war yeah
you can't put sometimes you see horrible
things that makes you give up on life
and what what these stories that have
been around so long are doing is that
they're they're helping them put all
this [ __ ] into context that you're not
the only one who's gone through this
this has been a human problem forever
forever and and and there's a way out
there's a way to navigate it there's a
way here's a boat and here's an oar
right now you're in the middle of the
sea on a raft and you don't know what
the [ __ ] to do and that's what that's
what mythology that's what mythology
does that's what metaphor does for us
that's what great story does that's what
literature does so
that anyway I just want to talk about
that is awesome I've been reading a lot
about how helpful it is from the people
have gone through it they're like this
is the first time I've been able to deal
because I've benefitted yeah yeah
definitely awesome yeah what do you got
June the first one is just a little
update on Tim McGraw he said that he
collapsed because he's been working out
too much do you believe this at all yeah
I do you do really well I think from
overtraining to like if he's on tour if
you watch that I dream despite you
haven't seen it in his life it's like a
documentary of him on tour and it's
insane it was on Showtime or HBO or one
of those networks was it like a few
years ago maybe and maybe I saw it
probably a year ago okay I was just
showing behind the scenes in the work he
was doing and then you're on tour City
after city like there's a reason and
everyone gives them [ __ ] for it ruin
Justin Bieber cancelled the rest of his
tour through and Kanye West did you know
how this like just cast a week being on
tour like what the [ __ ] man that you
know imagine a year later Taylor Swift
was on the road for one year playing
stadiums I mean that's every every other
day every day
I don't be like shut up you make so much
money
oh it's it's routes cry me a river no no
you're not understand here it's a
nightmare so for him especially and for
my thing beyond the road it's hard for
me to eat right hard on a schedule
that's your East Coast time they fly to
Midwest doing the press and doing press
what kind of food you eating you're
exhausted soundcheck and your singer
singing singing what 15 song how long is
the show but an hour and a half two
hours ours and you gotta bring it
yeah and then you have meeting greets
for the VIP sometimes I don't even know
if they do that are they even able to
but it's he said he to cut back on the
workouts yes that's why it was kind of
strange to me I get the exhaustion and
working like crazy hours and stuff but I
guess he does two workouts a day and a
yeah I was thinking too much I know
unless you're getting ready for bud yeah
oh you have a huge fight coming yeah
that never made sense to me that's a guy
my age who's gone I don't want to get
older and I want to stay trapped it's
like let's tigerboy to todd film and I'd
hooked him up with my box string goes
this house yeah and I'll talk to him
another day English dude I'm just
exhausted man like I had nothing
for a clan like we were hitting mitts
and my hands were heavy Mike why what's
going on well I doubt my other trainer
trainer come over before him and do wait
- oh I didn't know are you on UFC 226
yours why don't you um who's your
opponent you guys I've what do you mean
I go why the [ __ ] are you doing two a
day or an agent yeah what well I
wouldn't do that
well I'm doing how about when I'm
looking at different protein powders for
my shake we're at Whole Foods and I'm
with Brendan I go should I get the way
or do you think I should get a vegetable
protein and he goes doesn't really
matter does it huh for your performance
doesn't really matter does it like I
don't I don't think it matters for your
your upcoming physical race or fight
yeah you know are you piss hard right
you go piss out of your dick who makes
those men I like those that's who it is
no these are my rain boots what else you
got alright we just saw this together a
teachers investigative feeding up puppy
and other animals to a snapping turtle
in front of his students snapping
turtles don't eat puppies well they're
not carnivores are they I would imagine
if you give it yeah they are carnivores
but you know they snakes
snapping turtles do oh sure snapping
turtles are carnivorous
they'd fish I know well beep fish yeah
they'll eat a puppy no I don't approve
of this but that I you know what I call
[ __ ] - first of all if you're acting
this measure and you're gonna take a
little puppy and feed it to a snapping
turtle and you think you're gonna get
away with that in America when all of us
love dogs this much I had a guy riding a
gaijin
I had a dude when we played that a
stand-up gentleman from Leave It to
Beaver yeah or serial killer or a serial
creepy when we when we were talking
about that we played that video I guess
of that Leopard that that killed that
dog oh yeah a guy said I'm never
listening to show again my dog died he
was a cop I was copper as a soldier had
a canine wrote me a long email saying I
will never I've always loved your work I
wanted
I had to stop and punch my car's window
cuz my dog died on my chest
cuz there's my service dog I guess in
the military and you played that and you
guys were actually making light of it
which I don't think we were but we
weren't but no that way but I'm but I'm
sorry that the show almost a job why are
eating a dog
yeah something remote or no it was a
crocodile no no no it's crocodiles that
dogs like show the water yes but we also
showed we all showed you can hear the
dog screaming when this didn't oh yeah
yeah remember that no we never did that
Brogan played that before right no it
was us we played we played it but
doesn't matter the point is people get
people get very dogs are Americas that
we love our dogs if you're gonna be a
teacher and feed a snapping turtle the
dog you talk about you dog your ass no
go back that fin you talking about to
dog owners so we love dogs in must show
anyone sure if a video that's gone viral
on the internet of the alligators eating
someone's dog there's no volume on if
that caused you turn off the show we
don't need you this isn't a show for you
yeah but my sure I large smile are that
your own insecurity is my larger point
is that people get super emotional
person
you're not Michael Vick if you're a
teacher and you're about to feed a dying
puppy to a Sammy turtle I'm gonna go hey
[ __ ] are you kidding me right now
don't think about the kids like all Q
public
yeah that's not I wouldn't want to look
any evil snapping turtle is that
snapping Terry just see everything
that's food they'll take your hands off
counter had our run-ins with snacks
no joke their heart their dinosaurs
their diners oh so I guess he was
feeding the eunuch said oh boy guinea
pigs and Ikes
and snakes now were they alive when he
fed them that uncle crazy this guys he
must just be bored as [ __ ] as a teacher
going how can I mix it up today
you know life eats life and all that
maybe he's doing that maybe he's trying
to teach these kids horse feeding and
have the kids watch you got an egg
indefinitely he has to know he's gonna
get in trouble but maybe he's crazy
maybe his he's a cool teacher who really
brought science to life so that I love
his plastic because he had turtles and
snakes and other cool things okay
it was a deformed puppy that was gonna
die anyway I was
not okay my man it's very much circle
blood it's it seems very tough you know
it's not very well thought out kids are
gonna be traumatized you show me that at
34 I'd be traumatized here's my question
is it okay to feed it a rat a guinea pig
a squirrel and Bradley kids no yeah no
no no no what grade I'm not sure they
were they were they were an infant's
they were there are they worried they
were drinking milk from bottles you're
high weren't eating solid food yet
middle school junior high school junior
high is is a time when you cannot say
yes that's the other thing so we're
putting out we're putting a yeah that's
the big and then Zoey starburst yes
Leary used that Denis Leary's had this
really funny bit about how we don't eat
things that are cute like you're not
gonna eat puppies but you'll lead a
[ __ ] you know you're not gonna eat a
dolphin because they're cupid eat a fish
yeah so it's like I don't know he's
still employed and he's still getting
support from students and just made one
hell of a teacher and he must be a beast
of a teacher that was a deformed puppy
well I think that's just him trying to
show it's still torturing the puppy
though there's better ways to euthanize
a dog if it's yeah but still I what the
hell torture to have a snapping turtle
bite at this puppies that's a form of
torture yeah I'd rather not see an
animal die that quickly like that or
died that's awful to be fed not alive
[ __ ] snapping with us yet that's
[ __ ] terrible
somebody's snapping turtles are about as
big as you are have you seen how big
they are
remember were in Oklahoma yeah they're
I'm actually going back there you are
Angela hi god bless you remember
remember there was a giant that giant
snapping turtle that was literally how
big was that thing bro look at the size
of the thing was a think of a trash can
lid I was a 50-pounder look at that bad
boy look at that thing it's a dinosaur
yeah and those things are that's an
alligator snapping turtle okay they will
snap your entire arm oh yeah well there
there are a hundred and ten pounds or so
they're sweet and they later furry
lookin they are bad [ __ ] look
at that bad boy
that thing is the size of a man it's the
size of his head you could put your head
speak oh that can't be really no I don't
know no that's fake that's a regular
turtle that ain't a snapping turtle no
that's a snapping turtle alligators
never know manlius beaks oh yeah there
you that's a regular Astro like I had
when I was a kid now the one that the
girls up against no look at that that's
real that's Littlefoot you have no idea
what that movies from yeah Land Before
Time
Triceratops ducky yeah yeah you ready
yeah right you ready dude that thing
look at that pineapple next that thing's
mouth okay do you like celebrate yes I
have behind us man that's a pineapple
look at this watch this oh geez
imagine your hand in there chin no
snapping to lose your hand should we get
a snapping turtle to replace the zebras
not a bad idea that's really a good way
more gangster than a thing I like
snapping turtles me too I think it is
not a stuffed s snapping turtle they can
send us dude or how about a fake one we
should get a boy Cory who came to my
show
oh boy Cody ax coyote coyote who's Cody
coyote Peterson hey came to my show
which one in Arizona what a great guy
great guy great guy and he came with his
crew and thanks Cody and I was a long
time we weren't was it no no this was
two weeks ago three would seal yeah I
know I'm finally giving him a shout-out
great guy but dude that's crazy he's
catching big [ __ ] Turtles hey K
coyote this is your friend Brett here
let's not do our sideburns like that
though also look at the nails on that
yeah no I see the alligator turtle and
he's gonna do alligator to her things
hey Cody this side to our sideburns like
that and we're and we're the other jokes
man River got a long sideburns oh no no
a cool static tool hey kill gay coyote
let's not do our sideburns then leave
the little [ __ ] thing like you're the
backup singer of Nickelback let's not do
that
no it's coming back to the coyote let's
ditch the [ __ ] bleat or the [ __ ]
Backstreet Boy facial come on you're
being mean I love him man it's great
Louisville but shave your sideburns
all right things got some thick like
popper do you get that short fat dick
yeah I got that's a reference from the
HBO documentary about hookers yeah yeah
they miked up this short fat they miked
up this hooker and the guy goes yeah
yeah get it girl get it and here we go
ooh you got Ted short fat day it's a
highlight of the documentary HBO that's
the call it's like walking the streets
or something like that I seen it was by
far the highlight just this poor guys oh
you got that short all right and then it
continues with the soundbite of first
swallowing that short fat Tater Tot
really it's amazing documentary with us
yet soon all right so we lost a very
important person Stephen Hawking's
vision 76 if you ever see the movie the
theory of everything
I think haven't you don't know [ __ ]
about Stephen Hawking's watch that movie
yeah it's you realize how much of a
badass he was and also a heartbreaking
story to had ALS a doing ulterior
lateral sclerosis which essentially is
when all your muscles all of them just
no longer work anymore and you die he
was at 22 he was only given a few years
to live after being diagnosed with a
rare form of motor neuron disease
GameChanger his brain kept him alive
it couldn't speak what we do how about
his one wife left him out in the Sun to
die do you ever hear about that uh uh
left it on the Sun - it was that in the
movie no no looks like like two years
ago bring that [ __ ] up what wife tries
to kill Stephen Hopkins or leaving him
in this [ __ ] Sun was it just because
he was miserable or what but I want that
money son
abusing
she married him oh he married his nurse
his caretaker he left his a first wife
for the caretaker
I'm already I'm already I'm already got
scheduled I know that really happened no
I know but I'm already saying here
so letting him alone ain't been doing it
for money in his garden on the hottest
day of the year for so long that he
suffered a heart stroke and severe
sunburn she left him out there on
purpose try killing allowing to slip
beneath the water while in the bath
causing water to end to the tracheotomy
site and it's throwback shirt is the
fractures is wrist by slamming into the
wheelchair nice lady gasps his cheek
with a razor will spray shaving well am
i refusing him access to the urine
bottle and leaving him to wet himself
well yeah I would be very skeptical of
somebody marrying me in that condition
why are you doing it you know why are
you doing it
in the movie it's like a it's a real
love story but apparently she went dark
on him got leave him out in the Sun full
hasta a year it's a tough one can't
fight back I don't know how real
mastermind though yeah all right
Odell Beckham jr. one of my faves
there's a video circulating that a girl
made I guess he hooked up with a girl
and then she posted a small clip of them
on snapchat and looks like she has
cocaine she does she have cocaine and
pizza looks like a hell of a night she's
also a dime piece the other good scene
here a lot of people thought he was in
does not matter and I'd have no dog in
this fight a lot of people think he was
gay there does the rumors going around
we some I'm gonna fight on the field a
lot of time because people are making
fun for being gay that's a some of the
rumors this apparently not he likes a
dick suck in a pizza yep
and cocaine yeah beautiful man play he's
a much shorter person than I realized
thank you that's you're in the game with
it's the shortest clip ever you did
sleep wait that's it trying to get you
to sleep with some so sitting in there
New York definitely cocaine it box
well no it's definitely cocaine the
thing that bothers me about this is you
get that shitty Pete's especially in New
York how's that not artichoke pizza
which is delicious this is in France
oh wow yeah they what they met in a
nightclub in Paris oh and Odum says old
news stomach still makes a good story I
guess
ketchup we're in 2018 oh so it's a super
old video they think that's what he's
saying but they're saying it's actually
new but he's trying yeah this is my
thing and they're talking about this on
first date this morning shut out the
Steven F Smith and Max Kellerman to my
face
however you know some people well he's a
role model you know this lets everyone
down hold on Odom Beckham's how old he's
25 years old right 25 top of the world
table work it's his personal life right
and so he's hooking up with a chick
having pizza doing cocaine he doesn't
owe you a need a nation just because
just he's doing that doesn't mean he's a
bad person there's not a role-model
remark but he came from basically
nothing went to plateful my ass you and
they got trapped in the first round I
was the best receiver in the NFL what he
does in his off time and feels to do
cocaine he wants to [ __ ] dudes women
whatever he wants to do it does not
matter still Roma people expect these
guys to lift some fake life that no one
else is little hilarious what do you
think he's in duty let he was Lady
result in the bay and he's in would you
say France yeah it sometimes lobbies and
blows hey you want a dick suck in a
pepperoni pizza and a compliment I got
some of the devil's dandruff over here I
mean are you talking about the greatest
night man kid a man can't work his ass
off get to the top of the mountain and
[ __ ] let loose for one night well you
know you guys hating on him oh I know I
know he's supposed to be a great role
model again what you said he's 25 he
[ __ ] up sometimes whatever
oh he's 25 and and he has say 51 what's
up got all day oh and he's never failed
a drug test for the NFL or for college
Division one NCAA also he shouldn't have
say I didn't take any drugs it doesn't
matter the offseason I don't give a [ __ ]
what am i doing I don't know why people
hold them to these I'm doing my blow and
in spite and I don't do cocaine but
tonight tonight I'm gonna get my orders
I buy cheese PETA I'm not gonna be that
wired
yes you're you never even tried cocaine
how do you never know drugs over here
yeah really a little bit of weed I've
done
not a drug guy either I'm not I don't
like cocaine before I've done your
Dakota those work
I've eaten mushrooms before but not a
lot I'm not a drug guy and I smoked a
little bit of a em Jim Morrison and I've
done I've done DMT okay I've done DMT
yes you have but that don't count
does that count it's a psychedelic but
does drugs the only that's a natural
though yeah like I've done weed and DMT
that's it yeah I've said no to cocaine a
lot cuz I've been around it but I just
don't it's like I gotta wake up I don't
have time I actually don't like the way
it makes me I don't like I don't like
uppers yeah I I've done it you know a
handful of times we're also not the type
of guys I don't need drugs or alcohol to
have a good time around my friends or to
go out and feel horrible I'm good
alright I'm a water I didn't like the
way cocaine made me made me feel and
behave if there was a mound of cocaine
and a large cheese pizza and like
glitter you can only have one I would
choose that cheese pizza all da day
nobody did a lot of cocaine and then
things got better by the way
mmm everyone is liking how the sugary
always gone down down down hill on their
acting career and everything else I mean
the ones that I know of yeah I'm sure
there's ones we don't know if we're that
might be doing well yeah okay yeah
there's a lot I know you guys watching I
know we know I know
huhai of the boogers I know high
functioning artists who've done
incredible things and they are they love
cocaine was that guy from Saving Private
Ryan that was super good idea nice know
the UH he doesn't look like he's a
regular soldier
oh he was in heat too yes that guy Tom
Sizemore oh yeah he was also amazing but
then seemed like cocaine we had the same
age it wasn't just cocaine okay Tom
Sizemore god I know a little something
called that Matthew Chuck that's not
gonna get you you can't do that math you
lose T and he really did lose everything
and he was he was amazing really
important want to talk with him actually
about this it will t be such a really
cool guy movies why D movies Bheema well
so so there's only age so my my agent
was like Hollywood's waiting for him to
get clean cuz everybody he's on horrible
right now but they all want him so tell
me so he's a great actor but you just
can't he's got problems well why does
even his
[ __ ] profile shot there look like
he's high off his ass why is he here
why's he sweating their problems but you
know what he what's the last movie dude
check out hey look how many's doing yeah
oh dude he was across three yeah there's
a lot of stuff oh wow yeah he's stars
all 2018 - no my dude oh he's trying to
pay the bills
give me movies on 2018 yeah yeah that's
a lot okay so he still got it you can
make a comeback right he could or maybe
know sometimes just ships us to sailing
in the night like this this is shows
people that he's been sober for a long
time he'll definitely don't know and
they'll hire ya movies on Netflix and
there are too many roles for a guy like
that preach till to play like a like so
many different roles amazing I want to
see him he was so good in what was that
Black Hawk Don what was it he's great I
mean he'd he was amazing he was great in
a bunch he knows how to play like a
soldier in battle
so some actors that can actually they've
never done any military time everything
and they're able to make you believe
that there are war hardened [ __ ] like
oh dude he's holy he's always selling in
Philadelphia he was in that yes he's the
truck driver easily so that I got it you
know I'm not he's on that so he's the
one that talked about lot lizards never
seen it's brilliant
all right what else you got you what a
career so you guys know Cynthia Calvillo
tested positive for marijuana a while
back and she got a six-month suspension
he lost the fight - right she lost and
then she dissed by her if she lost but
she lost the fight you have my decision
my time okay
but yeah so the CSAC gave her like six
months or something like that and then
Nevada Nevada State Athletic Commission
is now giving her nine months I mean
it's so stupid I hate that I'm sorry sod
I gave her six months I thought it was
all good I know but then after they
tried it at NSAC
they gave her nine months for weed which
is horrible
you're a fighter why is we two [ __ ]
why is weed a problem it shouldn't be
it's [ __ ] stupid it's it can help
with pains and aches through camp it's
not giving anyone an advantage if that's
give me advantage and what's ibuprofen
and Tylenol doing right are you gonna
ban that it's so silly that's such a
shitty deal sweaty you know she's 30
maybe gonna get moving especially for a
female yeah you're moving fighting so
you pay the bills too yeah that's it
that's a shame what else you got -
alright this is a very sad one
there's not a Airlines United Airlines
so a flight attendant puppies today tune
carry on them me he I didn't bring it up
Wow do you have disgusted I saw this I
read this yeah yeah
so how is a flight attendant made a
woman take that little carriage thing
that the puppies in and put it in the
overhead over a cabin cuz it didn't fit
under the seat and then end up dying
after the dish you know there's a puppy
in there those he lied apparently she
lied after it seemed like oh I didn't
know was a puppy I thought was just
baggage but the guy the person was
crying when she was telling her put it
up there and she was like that's a dog
in there yeah what a bad person what's
wrong with people well in that situation
you can check it but if you check it
there's a whole protocol that goes into
that - right so she she was like put the
dog up there the dog will be sleeping I
can see how she'd be like that you don't
think the dog is gonna die when you put
him up there right out for me I would
say that that's better under a seat or
up up above yeah I gotta be honest that
why is it that why did the dog die
do they smash it in the bags not closing
what happens clothes so there's probably
less oxygen in there yeah I was gonna
say maybe there's no out of air yeah but
if you left it on your seat you have
that whole cabin with full of air
but in that little the dog died from
lack of oxygen not from you and rattle
I'm not sure what it died from unless
there's horrible Turkey yeah I feel like
okay I do too
I'm with the I'm kind of with this
flight attendant now to me I merely
think you can't put it up there well
because it's dark but you know the whole
the carbajal is dark too so I'll just
sleep right
I would imagine I mean how long is the
flight 4 hours 1 hour 2 hours how far
depends which is your hour flight or
flight site yeah but but I would say
we're gonna count for 4 hours
but it I don't think there's zero oxygen
up those aren't tight container not zero
but I mean just less it's probably
smarter chin I wonder feels rattling
around because I feel like if I was the
flight time like listen you should went
through the right protocol we can't have
a puppy thin there how about on takeoff
we put him up there
and then after he take off there I'm not
supposed to do this but you can get him
out and put him on your lap then she
gets in trouble yeah I don't know well
she's just [ __ ] trouble now yeah was
there a snapping turtle in in the actual
cat with her because you can't blows
dogless is that teachers it was the
teacher another puppy so the teacher had
the student teacher had his snapping
turtle in the compartment as well and
they don't tell you the teacher needed
another demonstration for the students
anyone dog was dead but the dog was also
in the belly of the snack this is
probably better for funny enough there's
another dog one there's a dog named yogi
the dog and it has a human face you guys
be the judge of it though well save it
as a human face does that look like a
human's Fisher does it no that looks
like a goddamn dog I'm serious like hey
Internet that is a [ __ ] dog he was
okay but it definitely doesn't look like
him
no there's making funny memes but still
look at this that doesn't look like a
human's faci at all not at all none
looks like a dog if I've ever season
looks looks look well let's take home on
his eyes are kind of getting hair it's
got a little nose it's got a little eyes
that are yellow
oh do I still use his eyes for [ __ ]
silencers let's talk as I say that's a
dog I would let me look let's go human
oh wait no it's a dog that's not are you
walking that human you know it's his
eyes and his eyebrows that kinda make
him look crazy his lips look bigger than
normal oh that's our lips you know I
still kind of looks like Brian I don't
know mister he looks like a baby Trump
no you know that looks like a dog oh how
about yesterday I'm with my son walking
around and I hate my whenever there's
planes my son goes Papa Papa points to
the planes and there's these two
jacked-up helicopters going because I
live by the Santa Monica Airport it's
going cuckoo cuckoo cuckoo
like treat military-style and then all
behind them is the president's
helicopter well they thought our Force
One in Force One at Air Force two right
what's that a copter call I figured I'll
check your chin but the heel ain't cuz
they land at the private Airport it was
pretty cool to see ya you know it's
Trump is still cool to see awesome yeah
it was so badass sure tho those planes
oh my god huh there's six of them bomb
just surrounding him Marine one that's
when I saw one that's it it was one
carrying the president the place around
him though they do not mess around there
it was like they're like helicopter
planes because they had the helicopters
things on top with a jet engine back
they're huge I thought oh my it's great
your take on this did we talk about this
how you know most Americans want the
economy to work for them a lot of
Americans don't have a lot of money
right they got five yeah and they want
their President to do a good job with
the economy they want oh we talked about
this distraction we talked about yeah
yeah you know the brain Buster's dead
what else get you a major league
baseball prospect has just been cut from
his minor league team because he was
caught in an elevator this has happened
- yeah like two years ago 2016 like
smacking the crap out of his girlfriend
he smacked her two years ago and they
just now he just found that footage yeah
and now he's in the big leagues now
no he's in the minors let me see this
video this is pretty bad dude so this is
in the stairwell I should say his name -
see he smacked her Oh a few times and he
drags her down the stairs and he picks
up her glasses smacks her again
backhander and then puts her glasses on
for her oh yeah alright what's good cut
that was did you see how he turned his
body no that's good cuz what's
surprising hits right yeah let's go
ahead and son I was talking her again
and then he's going upstairs she's
chilling he comes back down yeah so he
goes outside the door what's he going to
get I thought he's getting like a bat or
something no she was like she's like so
this is them again going down the stairs
and he's pointing at the top of the
stairs for some reason
and then check this out as he's walking
down she's not suspecting anything wack
and then now she's just on the ground
holy [ __ ] because he didn't hurt her
this is this is the reality and then
Rustica he does this again puts on her
glasses yeah because she she's crying he
doesn't anyone to notice Jim I keep
saying the glasses that's right it's
very obvious why he's doing it yeah I
just to me it's like you're like a
[ __ ] investigator who are you know
I'm Sherlock they put the big glasses on
because those are regular glasses yeah
but it covers the eyes of her crying and
black eyes
that's what pieces of do I don't think I
should never play baseball he's a bad
guy a terrible guy that's the only time
what makes my blood boil you wanna wish
I could see that if you had seen that
you'd give him a beating 100% and she
would probably defend him which is crazy
I'd love to see I'd be fine I stress pin
her like that and I'm going to take my
open hand and slap the [ __ ] out of him
I'm putting the glasses I'm gonna hold
him down and we keep on the glasses
Macker just finish your smacking knocker
put glossners hand into it I mean he's
getting his body into that no that's a
big-ass terrible terrible turning his
body into her oh that makes me feel sick
what a piece appointee get like 25 years
old who raised you looking a piece of
[ __ ] does it to women a lot of guys how
about that a lot of guys hit girls a lot
what else your chin man did you want to
say you got any more guys beating up
girls and puppies dying to know it's
never more bad you know it's [ __ ] up
though as a lot of women will tend to go
back to that guy I know or they date the
same guy over and over my friend my
friends behind an acting teacher and he
said he's talking about how people do
the same [ __ ] that's not good for me
because my sister is attracted to
dangerous men and she always dangerous
to date dangerous men they beat the [ __ ]
out of her and she finds another one and
she does so something drawn to it after
a while I guess I was just like you know
what you keep picking the right the same
guy over and over I love it the way they
were raised or loved that maybe their
dad beat them something like that you
know a lot of [ __ ] yeah apparently you
returned to the trauma sometimes you
know good god what else get gin let's
take a look at this so recently Trump
looked at the the wall prototypes that
he wants to have to build and then he
actually said something like
the Mexicans are great climbers they're
like professional mountain climbers
that's why that he was trying to give
them a weird compliment and obviously
didn't turn out well he's a character
out of here you go if you don't have
wall systems we're not going to have a
country there's a lot of problems that
makes it have cartels we're finding the
cartels we're fighting them hard
nobody has ever fought like you fought
them all right then he goes over the top
is easy they're like professional
mountain climbers their incredible
climbers they're resilient yeah yeah
back in Mexico find ways to get human
beings going to find ways to get Oh buy
a posse get out with third-world cuts my
thing about that's my thing about walls
I don't think you're gonna keep people I
know that's a distraction yeah that's
not the problem that's all a distraction
yeah the walls e-billing the walls of my
teammate eat them up you don't think
they're gonna find other ways or I
guarantee the figure out that wall and
dig under it do you think how they you
know tunnels or how do you think they
get to drugs yeah I mean this this wall
doesn't look fat crazy though right I
mean looks at face value it looks like
it's tall but you're over 18 and 2020
yeah trust me it's easy yes to figure
out drones to deliver heavy packages
will figure out drone it was like it was
like when those planes were flown in the
buildings in 2001 and a lot of people we
have to figure out a way to make
buildings that can take and I was like
that's not how you fight the problem
there might be another way to fight
there's not a very creative way to fight
the problem of illegal immigration
illegal immigration is a problem there
might be a better way than building a
wall that goes farther than you know he
real quick that's the biggest one I've
ever seen though that would be very
difficult I'll give that look at her
though if you have like a rope in those
things those crazy like first of all if
you have a Batman Batman anchor oh yeah
I'm up on that yeah I have one and I
have one it's gonna be [ __ ] tough
though man for women and chill for you
bro for you for big people we're not
gonna have a lot of big Mexicans in the
country but for people like me yeah it's
a distraction then you can do [ __ ] what
else get Jim let's take a look at
Richard Simmons
it's ordered by the courts to pay a
hundred thirty thousand dollars in legal
fees to the National Inquirer because
they reported that he was transitioning
into a woman oh wow and it was I guess
that alone is not worth like a defaming
someone so the court fees that they had
to pay to write that out you know
because they wrote that article to fight
Richard Simmons Richard Simmons has to
pay for it now Jesus Christ why so you'd
come up with stories I guess yeah the
Court finds that because the courts have
long held that misidentification of
certain immutable characteristics do not
naturally tend to injure one's
reputation even if there's a sizable
portion of the population who hold
prejudices against those characteristics
and transgender is not a Astral yemeni
so he's not getting affirmation of
character no he's not transitioning
right no he's a it's defamation of
character in the court say no it's not
actually huh just a rumor I guess that's
weird that it Jim that's pretty much it
well another puppy one just cause it got
puppies dying puppies puppy bite one
tie-rod bumblebees me and of and his
girlfriend and my girl from the time we
went and rescued Doug a dog for a dove
we got a dog from the pound
I never said she'd wanted to get this
giant
American Bulldog and got the dog and the
dog was kind of shy and kind of a dud
like it in terms of deaf wanted a badass
dog yeah
this dog was just super mellow probably
not dealing with a full deck to be quite
honest about as smart as a horse yeah
when you get a dog as smart as a horse
is a problem and he was real lazy and
the dog ran away to go yeah and then and
his girlfriend because she her mother
inning and mothering instincts like we
had to make fire that was like hey hey
just let him go he was like yeah that
was a big yeah yeah I was like he was a
minute I go you're not really that
concerned about your dog knows I don't
know
in the wild is happy it's in the wild
exactly that dog needed I'll tell what I
need Brian Andy be able to come out to
Oxnard Friday and Saturday this Friday
inside I'm coming out to see you I'll be
in the audience you maybe do a little
little time up if you want if you hey
I've been known to jump up just right do
it tight 60 65 minutes I'll do it quick
to attack yeah I might go a little over
and then you go up do you think the [ __ ]
is the problem I started Friday Saturday
might have a surprise guest from Bryan
Callen this Friday this Saturday Oxnard
Liberty live Late Show Friday Late Show
Saturday it's st. Patty's Day and then
the following week I am in Tampa the
early show sold out so there's only the
Late Show in Tampa on Thursday night
there's the 22nd next week 23rd 24th I'm
in Palm Beach Palm Beach improv Friday
and Saturday than Sunday
Orlando get you some and then the
following week San Jose and I keep
messes up San Jose I'm there Thursday
Friday Saturday San Jose
Thursday Friday Saturday I get you
tickets now to pack a calm down tell
we're gonna be glad you asked buddy make
sure you tell your gay friend in prison
right now
I sure will you right you know be in
Florida April April I'll be in April 8th
9th 9th 10th and 11th mmm I'm gonna be
and I'm gonna be in West Palm Beach oh
I'm in Florida I'm in Boston the next
weekend I'm in Denver that next weekend
so I'm I'm in Florida I'm sorry yeah
West Palm Beach April 9 10 11 April 19
20 21 me and mr. Rogan me and mr. Joe
Rogan are in boss and I'm at laughs boss
and he's at Wilbur
I think he's gonna open for me on
Thursday or probably even do an hour in
close I don't know we'll see I shouldn't
say that out loud but unless you know
brother how we were talking about it
today all right and then and then the
following week and the end of April amen
Denver buddy at colors that's my I love
it down there so there you are ladies
and gentlemen come see me Deepak a.com
for Brian and myself this is a fine kid
we're out